the sphere is the set of positions that
are all the same distance away from some
Center the skin of this tennis ball is a
three-dimensional sphere but spheres
also exist in higher Dimensions those
are called hyperspheres the
four-dimensional hypersphere has a
special name it's called a Glo a Glo is
the set of all points that are the same
distance away from a Common Center it's
just that these distances extend out in
four directions instead of the three
that we are familiar with an ant walking
on the surface of a sphere can move
freely in two directions latitude and
longitude plus any combination of these
an ant walking on the surface of a Glo
could move freely in three directions
latitude longitude and a third one hyper
latitude the Ant could move in any
combination of these and still not get
any closer to the center of the glob